through the haze sits the city of
tijuana
on this side of the border san diego a
crossing that sees 50 million people
pass through
every year but a border that still
represents one of the most divisive
issues in american politics
behind the replacement sections of
border wall ordered by donald trump
tens of thousands of migrants he decided
should wait in mexico
while their asylum claims are processed
but now
on the orders of joe biden the first few
finally being allowed into the u.s
the first bus carrying them a symbol of
a very different
immigration policy for those like felix
still waiting in tijuana after fleeing
gangs in honduras
and still too fearful to appear on
camera some hope at last
i'm optimistic he told us but the
numbers being allowed in are small
i don't know what will happen to me but
i'm more hopeful now
that's a feeling shared on both sides of
the border
this is a very historical moment and
we're talking about families very
vulnerable families that are fleeing
from sometimes our own government
from torture there are survivors of
torture
some are fleeing domestic violence and
so to have
people processed even if it's only 25
it's a huge step in the right direction
biden's reversal of a whole host of
trump's immigration policies is personal
for dulce garcia
a self-undocumented labelled illegal at
risk of deportation under trump
now seeing a new tone the biden
administration introduced a
bill and one of the changes in that bill
is to remove from the books the term
illegal immigrant
and this is something we have been
screaming at the top of our lungs for a
long time
to get rid of this hateful rhetoric this
isn't about sticks and stones
this isn't about hurt feelings this is
about how we treat
other human beings but a change of tone
has consequences
days before biden's inauguration a
so-called caravan of migrants
bound for the u.s from central america
clashing with police
the white house has warned that the
border is still closed
but many are too desperate to listen
and that worries even those here to help
people are starting to head in this
direction and so we're of course
very much concerned about what's going
to happen if they get here
and the country's not yet ready to or
able to
admit them and then what conditions are
they going to be living in
in mexico or wherever they end up
getting stuck
the routine of border life goes on here
the day workers who come over on foot
not as many these days a fact of life in
the pandemic
another crisis like immigration and the
border on which joe biden has promised a
solution
and which is now his to deliver greg
milam sky news
san diego